[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about digital
globalization talking about political
science talking about geopolitical
business strategy India China we have
dr. Matthew Rudolph joining us on the
show hello hello Alan thank you thing
coming on thank you for having to be
here yeah this is gonna be a lot of fun
I remember when we first met after Adam
Gazelle he's first fridays last month I
was super fascinated by your
geopolitical knowledge and I was like
let's do a show together so gonna be a
lot of fun and you have a very solid
background for this as well ten and a
half years is director of engagement at
the Ubuntu at work and that's doing
things like helping Asian and African
women escape poverty and that's very
exciting stuff because we've had him
again Wade on the show as well who is
doing very similar work with engaging
women and individuals in up-and-coming
economies to escape poverty super
important work and then also five years
as an assistant professor in the
government department at Georgetown
University and now most recently at ero
projects doing the chief adviser of
supply chain risk ethics and business
strategy there yeah so this is gonna be
a lot of fun very excited ok we're gonna
start with our big history take we love
starting this day so ok we find
ourselves stewards of earth after a long
period of evolution and here we are what
is your current synthesis on the state
of humanity
I am moderately hopeful for a variety of
reasons obviously climate change and
environmental degradation are the major
risks as a political scientist you know
I have to be concerned about political
disruption and war and conflict an area
that I used to study it's not a great
week for considerations of war in
conflict around the world right now
between the Korean Peninsula and South
Asia India and Pakistan but I do
consider major power war and great great
power conflict to be on the decline so
I'd put that at a lower probability than
risks from climate change
the reliance on fossil fuels carbon the
carbon economy is finally getting the
scrutiny that it needs so I'm less
concerned about that and encouraged by
the fact that a lot of people are
thinking about adaptation which I know
is a controversial topic I think it's a
good thing and it's important to start
thinking about it that doesn't mean that
those are certainties population growth
and poverty are major concerns and
combined with climate problems in
country areas like South Asia this is a
problem for at least those populations
if we're talking about global
civilization which is not something I
typically talk about I like to talk
about civilizations like the cynic the
Chinese civilization the Indic
civilization European or Atlantic
civilization multiple civilizations but
if we're talking about the global
civilization
I am moderately optimistic young yeah
and this is again your lens is this is
so important to identify it so that most
of the time when we when we speak with
other people around us in our little
bubbles of community we don't
necessarily reach out into what Asian
civilizations are like what is Chinese
civilization Indian civilization
actually like African European
civilization South American civilization
because when we and even then if we just
go and look at one little article about
something we're only taking one
perspective on the issue we're not
reading the dozens of perspectives on
that issue what is life like to be born
over there what stimuli do we absorb and
so having a fascination with that is
again this is one of the reasons why
we're here talking because of your
obsession with studying this and
learning and teaching about it ok so
let's talk about that obsession in that
journey you know you're a kid and you're
finding out you know who you are what
your character role is in this big story
of life
and so how did you land on political
science and Asia you had tremendous
influence from your parents yeah
political science as a profession ended
up surprising me a little bit the
interest in Asia particularly India and
South Asia
was part of a family vector my parents
were also political scientists they
spent most of their career at the
University of Chicago and so they took
me and my sisters I have two older
sisters to India with them when they
would go every four years so growing up
between the ages of 2 and 16 I spent a
year every fourth year in India
sometimes in parochial Catholic schools
sometimes in a boarding school in the
Indian Himalaya and then later when I
graduated from when I was in college I
spent time there
subsequently my professional career and
arms control took me there and then
later as I moved into political science
formally getting a doctorate in
political science I started doing
research and language training and other
things there so that's the story of it
but it started with my parents and their
fascination with it
and I happened accidentally to have this
with me today which is a book called
destination India published by Oxford
University Press that is the journal
that my mother kept while she and my
father drove from Calais in France all
the way to Madras what is today Chennai
in the Indian state of Tamil Nadu
overland in a land rover going through
all the countries in between that would
be a difficult trip to take today Allen
going through Iran Afghanistan at the
time Yugoslavia which was as they drove
through mobilizing for war in 1956 so
you know a tricky trip they did it they
did it without a weapon my my mother
always believed that it's more dangerous
to have one on you then
then did not and yet they did it over
land so anyway that's sort of part of
the the story and through my parents I
learned a lot about India grew up with a
community of people in North India known
as Rajputs these are the forum on the
former nobility and they they were a
group that my parents started studying
early on so spent time there but then
because of my experience in the Himalaya
looking across from the boarding school
I was that at the Chinese border I
started having an interest in China and
over the years got interested in Chinese
and Indian art so political science
ended up being an accident for me I was
an art history major in college I wanted
to go into art history but couldn't get
work and when I graduated in that field
when I was in Washington DC and at that
time apropos of what's happening this
week a lot of people were concerned
about Indian and Pakistani nuclear
ization yeah so I started working in the
arms control space and from there
decided I'd go into a degree in
political science so my passion is that
part of the world for those reasons
yes let's hit a couple of the Junction's
that you have stood on waited on their
way there you know first is it's so cool
that your parents got the chance to
drive you know from London after getting
to France on the ferry yeah all the way
to India and that that this is what
60-56 1956 56 in 56 this even being
possible is so important right because
thinking about trying to do this today
like why if the world has gotten so much
better
really right the better angels of our
nature why is it why can't we drive from
from France to India anymore yeah right
so these are these important questions
to ask ourselves and and so there's that
and then also that you know they were so
fascinated with studying and they
brought you along once every four years
in India so you got that deep immersion
into culture your
right that was very important in your
two sisters to do it so then you guys
all had your like perspective augmented
we're going into another culture you
know that's that in itself is already
you're seeing the world from another
civilizational perspective and so that
is all that's building up a stronger in
what I call a mental lattice right over
that multidisciplinary view of of the
world okay and then here towards then
you started indicating this you know
many people aren't necessarily studying
these conflicts that are going on across
the world and sometimes we're just
thinking of like you know Israel and
Palestine or we're thinking North and
South Korea or we're thinking what is
you know we don't really get to
sometimes a Pakistan and India yes and
so that has been a serious serious place
of contention so now tell us about you
know doing you actually went for a
period of time after you did the UC
Berkeley mhm and then you did um Taiwan
yeah actually so and I did spend some
time at UC Berkeley my my doctorate is
from Cornell University my undergraduate
degrees from Swarthmore College where I
did the art history but I spent time at
Cal because it is so strong not that
Cornell is not strong in East and South
Asia but Cal is is remarkable and I did
spend time learning Mandarin and Taiwan
and on the mainland so that is that's
the sort of development of the Chinese
angle that came later in my life and the
interest in China and particularly the
relations between China and India and
China India in the u.s. the triangle of
the three yes and that's this is again
one of these images that's so profound
is just taking and drawing a circle
around China and India and then saying
there's more people that live inside of
the circle then outside of the circle
right that one is a very profound mind
expansion which may actually soon be
changing in some ways with the
of African population there the I
learned that the statistic is their
median age on the African continent is
18 yeah they're very young India is also
quite young China is getting old fast
I think we tangled on this question of
the populations when we first met and
you did point out that one point for
each about in India and China yeah so
which I think brings us to about a third
of the global population you're with the
other two-thirds in the rest of the
world Bangladesh yeah yeah yeah South
Asia you know if you take all of South
Asia and all of Greater China then
you're getting close to half the
population probably but yeah so yeah I I
don't you know a consciousness of South
Asia this week of course you know we can
talk about this more but I'm sure the
Pakistanis are upset about Michael Cohen
being testifying in Congress and and
that the president is in Vietnam trying
to deal with the North Koreans because
it brings less attention to the fact
that they've been attacked by the
Indians or a retaliatory attack by the
Indians happened but we are talking
about two nuclear-armed countries if
we're talking about risk to civilization
you know the the risk went up this week
with the capture of an Indian airman
after an attack on Monday night our time
across the contested border in Kashmir
yeah
and this is one of the things that you
know people who work who are concerned
about nuclear escalation and the risks
of nuclear war put the South Asian
conflict between India and Pakistan
pretty high on the list along with North
Korea yes as as something to think about
and I just may thought I would flag that
as something that's happening as we
speak yes yeah yeah again this is one of
those contested areas and again this
whole know
of wanting control over land or you know
over money and greed and resources all
this type of stuff that human ethics
have a bit to go for evolution wise I
want us to just spend a little more time
here behind your eyes Notah in your in
your life story
um take us to you know what you're
learning as you're studying you know
you're there you were talking about you
know being there with your parents and
India experiencing this also you know
studying Mandarin as well so that's just
about kind of like what you started
seeing right well I mean an important
part of it was spending time in the
Indian Himalaya so from where I walked
to and from school I could see the
Chinese border I could see two or three
of the major points of Hindu sacred
geography and so talking about
civilizational centers right these are
the places where the Ganges River
you know originates and so you know that
has a profound impact on your
consciousness if you're thinking
regularly about that and that drove a
lot of my interest in that part of the
world and including seeing pilgrims
going to these various religious sites
walking days you know elderly mothers
walking you know miles and miles to
these pilgrimage sites you know
impresses upon one the power of faith
and of sacred geography so that I think
that's part of it the as I said I spent
a lot of time hanging out with the
Rajputs of North India the the former
nobility and you know this is in the
state of Rajasthan that abuts Pakistan
so again one side looking to the Chinese
border the other side and you're in
Jessel mere Rajasthan this ancient fort
on the Pakistani border you can look
into Pakistan so you know the geography
itself impressed itself upon my
consciousness in probably
shaped my interest in in in that sort of
Nexus of China India Pakistan and then
of course you know the politics of India
the world's largest democracy is
fascinating and over time as I started
to learn more about it sort of became
ever more fascinated by it and it stands
in great contrast to the world's largest
and most powerful authoritarian system
the Chinese and a very different system
of politics even though they both came
out of large poor agrarian societies at
the end of World War two they progressed
in very different directions and this of
course is one of the fundamental
questions of comparative political
science how do you end up with
comparative political systems democracy
in India authoritarianism in China and
the bizarre and very confounding puzzle
for economists political scientists and
sociologists that the Chinese have
educated and enriched their population
much more than the Indians have right
but this is a big problem for advocates
or promoters of democracy China India
contrast so the more I thought about
these problems the less I was able to
escape thinking about yeah incident is
that what you ended up spending a good
amount of your time on that come the
country the puzzle yeah subscribing yeah
the China India puzzle the problem is
that eventually the product the question
of authoritarianism versus democracy
becomes runs into a little bit of a dead
end there's you know until those
experiments are done yeah it's kind of
hard to say more about them and so you
have to drop down a level and look at
specific issues inside of the countries
and so for example my doctoral
dissertation
compared regulatory bodies in the two
countries specifically those regulating
finance right so how are non banking
finance regulated in China and India
particularly stocks and bonds so that
narrows the picture and looks at these
Qwest looks at the comparison in a more
tractable fashion and I always encourage
my students to think about big questions
but to research them from a narrow focus
and so over time I think you know the
field of fields of sociology economics
political science anthropology will
learn a lot from the current status of
China and India in their different
political conditions but by doing by
looking at small questions rather than
just the democracy versus
authoritarianism wouldja gets into a a
somewhat repetitive cycle at some point
yeah it does yeah it absolutely does
these conversations are happening around
the world on you know yeah
authoritarianism democracy capitalism
socialism and and it's just over and
over again just looking at kind of what
seems to be like worth running
simulations of what house Aviles ations
evolved and yeah we until we know you
know how to update the code most
effectively from our society and put
that to the test this is why
libertarians are kind of exciting to try
these little these little kind of niches
around the world of trying out certain
movement protocols that have yet to be
explored these are interesting
augmentations and code that I think we
can explore yeah okay so this is good
now now where did that lead you to kind
of how did you get involved in the the
Ubuntu at work yeah there yeah so I at
some point I do want to circle back to
libertarians in the Himalaya because
there's
very interesting theory and practice of
anarchism in the in in the Asian
Himalaya let's black bracket that do
that do that now and then we then I can
get back to Kubuntu at work and focus on
livelihoods income generation in
low-income countries in general yes but
again circling back to the point where I
told you I would walk to school every
day in the Indian Himalaya
and look at the high Himalaya the
populations that now occupy the space
that more or less goes from the
mountains of Afghanistan across the
mountainous zone all the way into
Southeast Asia Burma Laos and Cambodia
the mountain zones there is all one
chain of mountains and there is a theory
that is contested I think it's one of
those theories that whether it's true or
not causes us to think in very
interesting ways about a part of the
world and about ways of being ways
people are in the world but it that area
is described by a Dutch anthropologist
as zou Maya and it is occupied by what
he calls anarchists and the Yale
political scientist James Scott has
written a famous book called the art of
not being governed yes that is about
this population and how he believes as
does the his his colleague the Dutch
anthropologist that these occupants of
Zumaya are escapees from organised
civilizations religion armies taxation
masked agriculture and that they fled up
into the mountains to get away and they
are the original anarchists and so
that's an important and interesting
theory what are their practices how do
they govern themselves yes
they meditate so much that they are able
to encounter another human beings yeah
not pop them over the head or their land
and your etc yeah then you can actually
slowly figure out how to work together a
social platypi mates yeah although and
it is also true that most of the ones
particularly the sort of most and
artistic ones are nomads right they are
there they do not tie themselves to a
specific piece of land which is
important so there's a fundamental
element of this problem anyway but if we
if we think about libertarianism and
anarchism it's important to put it in
contrast to other issues and you know
James Scott has now recently come out
with another book called against the
grain which is not about how people in
the bay area are gluten free it is
actually about how organized agriculture
was one of the driving forces for the
establishment of violent Orthodox
organized civilizations that provide the
context for anybody to want to be a
libertarian or an artist so that is you
know the arguments behind against the
things that having agriculture draws
people in to live in these these cities
you can supply more food to more people
they can live more densely yeah but then
it makes you larger target for military
to take the food right is that the thing
that so that is part of theory once you
have surplus from agriculture yes you
then are a target it also means that the
state itself can begin to specialize so
you can have armies that can then attack
other places and you have more complex
social organization where you need
ideologies or systems of control such as
religion caste systems hierarchies and
you have the ability to tax sir
plusses so taxation armies orthodoxy
ideology are all outflows of of fixed
agriculture so 10,000 years ago we
wouldn't have even now thinking back
most people associate the religion to
all this
this control systems were 2,000 years
old they say they're yeah but this is it
goes back 10,000 years to egg because
egg kind of domesticated us in a way
that's so interesting and then the
control systems came up it's so many
other ways with the cities of God and
this is you know this is part of the
Mesopotamian what is now Persian Iran
and Harappa and mohenjo-daro and in
northwest india these are the same
disavows yeah indus valley and likewise
in the Yellow River and Pearl River
zones these three great zones of
civilization Genesis you know all
conform roughly to to the Scott and
other theories on these things it's very
interesting I'm gonna have to dig deeper
into that and hopefully we can feature
more of the leaders better that are
figuring that out world now just another
quick thought that I think you might
find interesting is that when you find
yourself kind of in this like you were
explaining this you're up in the this
version one of the anarchists of we
don't subscribe to your governor my eyes
oh my it's called they call it Zumaya so
Maya yeah when you find yourself as oh
my it's it's it's it's um it's quite
also humbling to where you see the start
of these really important rivers to gain
these river but not where you're seeing
this you also don't necessarily you're
not there's I guess there's a there's a
view that I hope to share with people is
that if you you know barricade off that
that initial water supply and then you
when the people come up and say why are
you barricading the sovereign and you
say you have to pay me in order for me
to who let it roll and here are my guns
protecting me so right there's there's
different ways to be
as civilizations evolved so that you can
play in a more cooperative right game
yeah yeah well unfortunately the current
history of the Indian and Himalayan
watersheds is not despite what I said at
the beginning of the of the program is
not all that good so yes on February
14th Indian paramilitary forces were
attacked by Pakistani based terrorist
group the next week the Indians
threatened and are taking measures that
probably will end up renig Anana deal
that they have with Pakistan for the
sharing of those very waters of the
Indus River that we just discussed there
is a treaty that the two countries have
that has more or less stood the test of
time three major Wars lots of points of
tension up until today and if the Indian
government goes through with this the
misery of poor people in Pakistan who
rely on the flows of water from that
treaty agreement are going to suffer
badly and those poor people in the
lowlands of Pakistan probably had very
little to do with the attack on the
Indian troops
similarly North China is experiencing a
major drought and if you want to talk
about risks to you know the Chinese I
beg your pardon your Mongolia well no
like even the area of near Beijing and
basically the whole North East quadrant
of China is in is already in technical
drought and you know their measures are
being taken and it there's a lot of
concern that it will get much worse
the Chinese have plans now to start to
hurting the waters that flow from the
himalaya now through the Brahmaputra and
other waterways through India and into
Bangladesh and people who are pessimists
about this who or who are let's say more
hawkish on this issue in India believe
that there will be a war or intense
conflict between India and China around
that water and the demise soon demise of
the so Mayans that we were just talking
about these anarchists who live in the
uplands of of India and China and Upland
Asia are all going to suffer and are
already suffering because of the
militarization of the Himalaya so
railroads roads airfields waterworks all
of the things of the civilization brings
people are moving into the Himalaya as
part of the potential water conflict
that is coming there yeah I really
appreciate your your lens on all this
this is this is so enlightening already
um ok let's do let's you do you boom -
ok - at work you know we could talk
about it boo - at work the it's an
organization set up by its founder of a
peg leg it was now currently on hold as
we have some governance issues I have
taken what I learned there which is the
reason I got into a bun - at work was
because having studied low-income
countries in South Asia like India and
Pakistan and China which was once a
low-income country now a middle-income
country a lot of people even described
India as a middle-income country but
that's only because they have a lot of
really rich people along with a lot of
very poor people but I wanted to learn
more about grassroots rubber meeting
road development work and what that
means I also came to understand some
time ago and now I think many more
people understand it although it's
embarrassing that I didn't under
at that time the horrible condition of
women in South Asia generally and in
North India in particular and so lubuntu
at work was particularly focused on
livelihoods and self regard for women
and so that is what took me into that
work and the work that I'm now doing on
supply chain ethics and an analysis that
is more focused on Africa where there
are similar conditions of for women and
for livelihood of low-income people is
what's taking me into that in the
agriculture space particularly with nuts
cashew nuts and other types of nuts and
that's all of a piece this was you know
I had studied elite politics I'd studied
global conflict conflict prevention but
I had never really looked at the at the
grassroots level the individual level
and the condition of women and so that
is what took me into that that space and
that's very very important to talk about
that when we when we sat down with me
get to her her ability to teach us about
what happens when you when you're able
to provide someone with these economic
degrees of freedom yeah to enable them
to escape poverty with having something
to do every single day that they enjoy
doing that provides to them with meaning
that provides them with degrees of
freedom but as well and takes them away
from all the violence potential that yet
that this is that assertion and
incredibly important thing right and you
know these the positive change is not
going to happen just by you know global
summits and treaties and all the rest of
it it will happen because the genders of
all types become more equal because
economic inequality or at least absolute
poverty is diminished
and so opportunities are provided and
opportunities and then though like you
were saying with supply chains Stephanie
yeah it was also teaching us about how
there's just some just some egregious
policies and regulations that are
occurring that prevent like the import
of a certain good or the highly taxed
threat the import of a certain good that
makes it really difficult to be able to
produce that final product area yeah and
yes these are all this old lines of code
that need to be updated right well that
I mean taxes or tariffs you know this is
a interesting issue and optimizing them
is what trade theory and economic policy
is about we're learning more than we
ever the one positive thing about the
Trump era is that I don't think any
American who you know could read during
the last three years will ever have the
same types of questions about what a
tariff is that my students did a decade
ago so for good and ill people are
learning about global trade in a way
they never had before in the u.s. at
least and
about five five thousand or so female
yes right so again we're we're in a bit
of a hiatus or a holding point right now
but during the decade or so of the
active high active operation we helped
about 5,000 women with a variety of
different what are called in this area
business services things like helping
them with inventory helping them with
entrepreneurship activities the main
most effective channel that the BAP
ingly devised and then promoted was the
use of workspaces so this provides a
safe workspace where people can come and
do whatever work that they have on their
own Lubuntu then had contracts for
various types of work that we could give
people if they wanted
additional income and the main thing is
having them on site then even though we
did not provide microfinance or did not
provide financial inclusion or other
things we could put them in touch with
people that would do those things or
mobile telephony or computer literacy in
many cases just basic numeracy by
partnering with other people having
women on-site at the workspace allowed
us to provide these services and it is
you know it's sort of the story of if
you have one goat and then next year you
have two goats that's 100 percent growth
for that person that's a significant
increase right if you one year don't
know how to operate your mobile phone or
you don't have a safe place to check
your inventory and count your money and
then in the next period you do have
those things it's a major improvement
yeah yeah okay so how much of what your
if your of what you've been teaching us
from your research in India China and
the Himalayan and the what you're just
saying about Ubuntu how much of those of
that synthesis were you also teaching at
Georgetown or which aspects of the five
years yeah at Georgetown I
I taught sort of three different
channels one was conflict in Asia which
has been you know an area of interest to
me since I left college and started
working on arms control issues India
Pakistan Korean Peninsula India China
violent conflict in Asia so I taught
courses on that and then my other area
of interest is the political economy of
Asia so I taught courses on business
government and globalization with a
focus on China and India basically how
have the Chinese and Indian economies
globalized yeah more or less in the
period since 1980 let's call it and that
had a large
focus on finance and on models of
development and the authoritarian versus
democratic contrast and then the larger
question of comparative politics in
general
so where do states come from right this
question of civilizations India and
China had some of the earliest and you
know most people argue the establishment
of something that we would call the
state first happened in China with the
development of a bureaucracy and
examination system a what we would
consider today a organized state first
emerged in China the Indians
Mesopotamians a bunch of others you know
came along with those as well so
comparative state formation how our
states formed the question that you
brought up of war and capture drives a
lot of that which eventually kind of
dovetails with questions of conflict so
you can see the beginnings of emergency
overlapping so at Georgetown I taught
these three things violent conflict in
Asia political economy of Asia and
comparative politics almost always with
a focus you know sort of centrally on
the China India comparison but with the
rest of Asia and the rest of the world
in in view as sort of a preview to
another part of what's going here is the
civilizational element and you know this
once you can't talk about China or India
or Sinek or index activities without
thinking about civilizations yeah when I
was in graduate school was when the
famous political scientist Samuel
Huntington published his article The
Clash of Civilizations wondering what
will happen to the global politics after
the end of the Cold War the Cold War
organized global politics for a period
from 1945 to the period until 1990 what
happens after the that organizing
principle of
war diminishes or
shrivels and huntington said we will
have a clash of civilizations it was a
complicated thesis most people disagree
with it today but it still provoked a
lot of thinking yeah it inspired the
revival of civilizational thinking my
advisor at Cornell a fellow named Peter
katzenstein who has you know along with
Huntington and others helped revive this
interest in civilizational thinking
comparative civilizational thinking dear
not a single global civilization but
comparative civilizations based around
the axial religions Buddhism Hinduism
Christianity Islam began to grow and so
this question of
how will civilizations comparing
competing cooperating be a new
organizing principle is a question
that's out there and has most important
question that's out there how do we
eight billion of us write work together
right yeah yeah and you know
civilization the coop international
cooperation person-to-person cooperation
firm to firm cooperation these are all
other things that I think matter and and
and units of analysis that matter for
thinking about that problem but
civilizations are probably the largest
one or geographies yeah they're probably
the two largest units you can think of
yeah and so trying to analyze
civilizations becomes important and
again is organized right and so then the
question of India as one node or hub of
civilization and China as another node
and hub of civilization is an important
part of that civil comparative
civilizational thinking and so that you
know moving you asked about what I
taught about it when I think about when
we think about states those are fairly
large units Alliance groups are another
one but then we go you know the next
level highest level is civilizational
forms of organization and then this is
also kind of a good way for us to tie in
as we talk about these we have kind of
we've been talking about these as as you
know we said a civilization as a node
let's say like India or China and then
we maybe talk about things at another at
another level like a geographic code
that's written for people to live in and
then there's this company and sometimes
sometimes you see a Google which has a
YouTube which has two billion eyeballs
watching videos every single day and
what is the code that that works on or
$0.10 what code does that work on and
Facebook etc these and so now I would I
would like to ask you about this you
know California where has this Hollywood
Silicon Valley and it's the six
largest economy just in the world just a
state of California is bigger than
France and this is this is some insane
stuff of what's being pumped out of here
in terms of entertainment and technology
right and who is who's working together
that who's were the ethicists and
philosophers working with the engineers
and is that happening in authoritarian
China as well who's also commanding one
and a half billion eyeballs right well
you're bringing in the California piece
and since there's worse egg waiting from
civilizations it's important to remember
that the technological part of
California Northern California the Bay
Area and particularly the internet and
digital globalization of this Bay Area
was driven not exclusively but
significantly by a diaspora that came
from Taiwan China yeah and from India
right and so both the melting the
original coders and entrepreneurs and
then later large pools of capital were
organized by these diaspora so China is
a Mississippi Northern California and
the Bay Area is a nexus of the Chinese
and Indian and the North American and
what I find interesting is the
globalization of California through
those channels and how the rest of the
world is responding to what the platform
monopolies Google Facebook Amazon is you
know Seattle but has activities here
Netflix of course is here and so the
globalization of Northern California is
you know sort of underway still we're
still trying to wrap our heads and and
minds around what that means but it is
certainly a juncture for all of these
things and trying to understand
what the shape of Californian
ideology but you know this to lay it out
there there's a famous 1995 article
called the California ideology by barb
Brooke and and camryn that you know was
written in 95 and has been controversial
ever since and is you know the question
that drives a lot of people who are
interested in California what happens
here the mix of hippies libertarians
technologists and military industrial
conflict the complex who gets all four
of these coming together you know even
before you get the Indian and Chinese
diaspora coming in so this is how to
think about what's happening in
California and it is one of the few
places where libertarians of of the sort
of Bitcoin blockchain cryptocurrency and
techno utopians who believe that the
space of the Internet provides an
analogue to the Himalaya as a place to
get away from states and organizations
and orthodoxies and taxation and all
those things come together here in
California and so certainly that part of
the Californian ideology is inescapable
or not inescapable people can escape it
I'm saying is a is a distinct part of
what would define the Californian
ideology how its evolving is a is
another question I don't you know given
time it was a quick bit on on your
perspective on the evolution of this
yeah well so the Californian ideology is
both changed and in force reinforced by
the arrival of the the platform
monopolies the fangs Facebook Amazon
Netflix and Google right and for
libertarians there's an interesting
problem which is why are there loop in
the Apple LinkedIn into
you're absolutely that's true Apple
LinkedIn and Twitter
Apple has doesn't have the monopolistic
control although it is the richest you
know one of the richest companies
although it isolates they are close so
we can certainly loop them in but
regulating them you know what's
happening now with the backlash against
them and the idea that the state should
come in as the European Union has done
with your GDP are the general data
privacy David
privacy regulation GDP are and
California is now beginning to do and
other state governments around the US
federal system are getting into is a
question that you know challenges the
California not ideology at least a
libertarian part of it from from a
complicated and difficult perspective
monopolies are just as powerful as
States these these companies are proving
that right in some cases they're more
powerful than most states on the planet
so what to do about that and that is I
think that is that is causing a
reckoning for the way Californian the
Californian ideology had been going rip
ship algorithmic bias rest types of
things are insanely important to talk
about right and what should be done
about them right if you're taking a pure
market perspective it's hard to say you
can leave Facebook sure you can leave
Facebook but there's no other social
platform that you can go to the network
effects are very strong to network
effects her you can't run away from that
right so this this becomes very
difficult you want to disseminate your
ideas right then you have to wait yes so
this is the monopolistic or at least aa
oligopolistic power of these players
challenges the anti statist element then
you've got the cryptocurrency dimension
that is also challenging this on the one
hand
currencies are part of the techno
utopian element of the Californian
ideology a way for us to get away from
states from the federal reserve from
taxation from these other elements that
many and our kists including the so
Mayans fled and yet even that is being
captured crypto currencies are we going
to have a corporate cryptocurrency run
by the consortium anchored by Goldman
Sachs are we gonna have one that's
controlled by the group that's involved
with the Winklevoss twins who is gonna
you know do we now have a competition
for what was initially an artistic
sector that's right and Wheatley
decentralized way for us to exchange
right value with each other yeah yeah so
this is you know I thought I observe
Ingush in Northern California and
observing the the way Northern
California is connecting to the rest of
the world and provides an example right
once again if you are a politician
sitting in India or in China or in any
other country and you somebody says to
you what do we need to do to develop
economically you say we need to build a
Silicon Valley we need a cluster that's
right so everybody wants to be like
Northern California Piero's showing
cluster everyone's asking him that
question yeah what are you in this area
cluster development is is is important
and maybe KY miracle it may not be
possible it there's a sort of secret
sauce though there are certain key
ingredients institutions of higher
learning yes
artists creators yes a port is generally
a good thing the great thing a variety
of other things that tend to be useful
so can Silicon Valley be reproduced
certain ways possibly we kind of see it
in in Hong Kong a little bit you know we
kind of see it and this you know tiny
bit we can say in like Tel Aviv as well
there's an interesting little law well
in Bangalore Mangalore Beijing the Pearl
River Delta the in most in many of these
places I mean Tel Aviv has a creative
element I understand but you know the
magic of Northern California and you
know we haven't even talked about the
agro business here right the Central
Valley is connecting here crazy cannabis
wine these are all other parts that
contribute to the Northern California
economy and that are parts of the way it
all coalesce is together yeah I'm glad
that you brought the egg piece and
because we were sometimes we get so in
our Silicon Valley bubble we forget
about Hollywood in LA and then we forget
about Central Valley which is where we
get so much of our egg from and then we
forget about Napa and Sonoma
we're wine and then we forget about
Humboldt with cannabis and it's just
funny that this is why California so
raging and in many ways you were talking
about the Diaspora of China and India
that are also here doing work
there's the diaspora of just south of
the United States in Mexico Central
America South America that are here
working really hard and producing a lot
as well and when we you know just had
Diego Vela on the show I'm an
anthropologist a social ecologist you
know he and other anthropologists say
things like it's become ridiculous when
when you say things like no no no you
know you stay passed south of the border
but you know if you want to come work in
in the kitchens and work in the fields
and stuff we'd love to have you this is
[ __ ] this is this has been built up
so much it's been such a harmonious
energy over the last especially 150
years of this of this western part of
the United States being built up in this
way and I'm happy that you know we've
touched on a kind of like one of the
core I guess pillars of what we've been
talking about is how do we then go
getting into this age of the of the
digit of the digital globalized world
do we update the code most effectively
as we look out the Indian civilization a
Chinese civilization the you know the
Silicon Valley one is being built here
in Bangalore Hong Kong et cetera that
tel-aviv how do we work together across
these hubs to ensure a collaborative
ethical moral just framework for
civilization well I turned to a mentor
and person I really admire on this
Kavita Ram Dass who used to be at the
Ford Foundation now is a Global Fund for
women and her answer to this question
which she is often asked is tend your
own garden 100% focus on the areas that
you can control that's a sincere self
work yeah yeah nothing I just your own
work but in your own neighborhood yes
yes you know I would commend to people
the way that Californian ideology is
being changed in the ways you just
mentioned next Tuesday logic magazine
becomes - and at City Lights bookstore a
key part of of California more Weigel
who talks about labor inclusion women
all these things in the tech industry
and that that magazine is devoted to
talking about you are focusing on
tending the garden here in Northern
California and the changing the
Californian ideology to acknowledge the
problems you're talking about Metheny we
got a feature we got to have you back to
keep unpacking this stuff we also have
to feature more people in your this
network of leaders that you've been
talking about that are that love I love
it yeah tending tending the own garden
I'm okay just two quickies on the way
out this is simulation are we in a
simulation when I was growing up I often
wondered if I was in a simulation as a
as a youth development thing it
regularly occurred to me and I wondered
whether I was part of the simulation and
I don't believe so I think we are agents
and can change things ourselves
I mean this is the question of the
Kobayashi Maru from the from Wrath of
Khan Star Trek you know can you get out
of the simulation and change it but I
don't believe so
okay and then the last question who what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in the world
mmm
hi al pijn mountains
tell us more the undisturbed beauty and
majesty of nature yes in the
connectedness that that brings yeah
Matthews it is such a pleasure thank
wise thank you so much for coming on
wonderful being here such an interesting
time talking about all that stuff thank
you yeah you're you're so welcome your
wealth of knowledge and we look forward
to continuing talking about
civilizations in geopolitics and all
that goes into this I'm really excited
thank you thank you thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we
would love to hear from you and your
thoughts in the comments below do let us
know what you're thinking huge shout out
to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing we love you very much and join
the community guys get your thoughts not
only here in in what we're talking about
in our community chats but go and talk
to other people about this talk to other
people about geopolitics about political
science about what's going on in other
parts of the world keep sharing those
messages around support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in around
the world in your community support them
if this content is useful to you all our
links are below to support us check out
Matthew's links as well below go and
check out his work more supportive as
well and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you so much and we will
see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]